Okay.
Alright, let's go to our caller from the nine
one five area code.
Who's calling today from nine one five.
Hey, David, it's Justin calling from Monroe,
Washington.
How are you doing today?
Uh, oh.
Not too bad.
And I was, uh, wondering, putting aside all
value judgements and stuff like that the Republicans
take on the shootings.
The recent shootings have been to, of course,
blame video games and their younger voter
block, especially those that populate like
the Donald Subreddit and for Chan and stuff.
Uh, there's one thing they love more than
Donald Trump.
It's video games.
And I'm wondering how that plays from like
a political move to try to alienate those
people.
I'm not sure.
I am so, okay.
Let me see if I understand your question.
I want to make sure I answer it correctly.
You're saying that the same people that love
and are in these online alt-right enclaves
also love video games.
Is that right?
That's what you're asserting?
Yes.
A lot of them really do.
Okay.
And then you're saying that they are being
alienated by the discussions of what a video
games being to blame for the shootings?
Yes.
Oh,
uh, listen, I don't know that all online outriders
love video games.
I just don't know if that's the case.
Uh, I'd have to, you know, maybe that's true.
I'm not sure.
Uh, I think that it's wrong to blame video
games for the violence.
So I think that that is also a problem, but
I don't know that I am sort of like lined
up with the way you're framing the questions
such that I can really answer it.
Oh, while they, uh, a lot of, uh, white nationalists
rat a radicalization comes from the idea that
young white men don't have any sort of, uh,
[inaudible] banner to rally around.
Like, you know, women do or other minorities
and a lot of them took up the game of are
the tag of Gamer [inaudible] as they're, you
know, on press quote unquote a group.
Yeah, I mean that's what caused the Gamer
gate thing and all of that.
I see.
So a lot of, all right, you're sort of suggesting
damn players, this group under Gamergate,
which if you don't know about Gamergate, I
wish I was like you.
I wish I didn't know about it either, but
years ago there was a thing called Gamergate
and so you're saying that Gamergate became
a rallying cry for a group whose identity
would not normally see them as the victims
of anything in society.
They were able to say we are now the victims,
we are the oppressed, we are being targeted.
And that gave an identity of assort which
was then radicalized into the outright.
Am I sort of understanding?
Yes sir.
And that's a lot of the people that populate
these Internet forums that are, you know,
mostly young white men.
Interesting.
Well listen it, this isn't the first I've
heard of it, but you're presenting it in a
very kind of like cut and dry causal way.
I don't know for sure how much there is to
that.
I'm not discounting it, but it's certainly
something I want to look into more.
All right.
Okay.
Very good.
Justin.
Thanks for the call.
Great to my call.
Yes, of course.
My pleasure.
Great to great to hear from you.